[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi i'm dan hayes i'm joined by my
co-host dr greg sadler today we're
talking about
parasocial relationships so if you
haven't heard of these before this is
when
you're in love with a
character or the actor who plays them
and you think that they care about you
as a person or it could be all sorts of
other people as well so we've we've got
a lot of interesting
examples and insights
and i i would
actually
let me just lay my cards on the table i
think people have a lot more of these
than
they would admit to
it unless you actually start asking them
kind of deeply probing questions what
what do you think dan do you think that
you think i'm off on that or you think
that's probably right i think it's it's
we're in its heyday now with the advent
of youtube and streaming in which you
can have
a long-term interaction with people
on a day-to-day basis
yeah um
it's it's here and that's uh i don't see
it going away anytime soon
yeah so that brings up a good point and
later on in the episode we're going to
give you some some advice or some
practices that you can
use to be what would we say less
less ensnared by these less driven by
these less taken aback by these um it's
not to say that parasocial relationships
are automatically bad or
that you should take all of them out of
your life and you know live very
realistically or something like that
but
we do have to kind of watch it don't we
yeah that's like anything taken to an
extreme
can result in you going and making
really potentially poor decisions and so
you want to try to
reduce those poor decisions that's a
good way to put it yeah
so what are parasocial relationships um
it's a very fancy word uh i don't know
that everybody's
used to hearing about them in this way
it is a a
pretty common sensical concept i think
once we hear what it is but what it what
so dan what are parasocial relationships
these are the relationships that are in
a sense not really relationships in that
they are
kind of one directional okay most
relationships you have a give and take
there's a reciprocity within them but uh
you know
take uh if you are super enamored with
um i don't know jennifer lawrence and
okay just love all of her films and you
um read all about her in the magazines
and follow her her ups and downs of your
relationship so you feel like you're so
just right next to her but she doesn't
know you at all is that a relationship
even though you feel very close to this
person
so
what if somebody was like well it is a
relationship i can you know i can tell
that they're speaking to me through the
the tv there's like a a code
would you say well that's
you know now you're really going off the
deep end
uh well it depends on how much i know
that person and how much i want to try
to deduce their state of mind
um but yeah like that i would say if if
we're being like totally open and honest
that that is
something that you should probably
curtail that that uh
that way you know stalking goes
well here here's another way of
softening it what if somebody says about
i don't know a celebrity or a character
i mean it could even be
um somebody who was created to sell
cleaner or
tissues or something like that like mr
brawny or mr clean or
if somebody says hello kitty
yeah there you go somebody says
they really get me now they don't mean
that like
you know somebody's writing them emails
and saying oh how are you doing today i
just wanted to make sure that your
kitchen was clean or something like that
but there's something about the ethos of
the person
that the
lover the the relator finds appealing or
finds congenial
um is there any is there anything wrong
with that
i
as long as you know what it is then i'd
say no like
i can
read a author or philosopher that's been
dead you know hundreds of thousands of
years and i can feel like oh this this
guy's really getting
uh at something and is really hitting a
nerve that that resonates with me
once again
um
doesn't
automatically confirm a relationship and
so like pera means beside and so like
where we're it's it's not the regular
social relationships that we have but
it's it's this kind of a side to that
okay
um so
for example um we kind of define these
things as one sided um non-dialectical
you're not actually in a conversation
with this person but you're you know
just having stuff uh given to you
that um it's the what is presented is
usually controlled by the performer um
and uh this does not actually create uh
mutual development so you can like make
questions about like some of the the
youtubers even you know greg here who at
least respond to some uh
you know comments on the videos but that
doesn't automatically mean that that is
you know a
the dialogue that is usually reserved
for a you know
closer relationship um and also this is
like our relationships that actually
recur over time
um
are are harmonics of actual
relationships but um
they're they're also here in the
parasocial that you know you're you're
following this person very much what you
would with others and um you know
there's uh it all this creates an
illusion of intimacy that
um you know as i
mentioned just before that you know
especially if you're like
sitting on a several hour long like
twitch stream with someone yeah that's
an experience that you almost
never have with anyone besides your
close friends or family who you're
hanging out for long periods of time
with well you know that's interesting
because i was just talking
earlier today in an online session that
i do is one of my perks
for
people that are interested in hegel
and
one of my one of the people that i've
been interacting with boy since i think
i want to say like
2013 2014
is a retired guy
down in texas
and he and i communicate pretty
regularly and we've gotten to know each
other pretty well and he was talking
about the joe rogan podcast
and having watching it and he was
telling me about somebody who was on it
and he says you know i can't watch these
these joe rogan podcasts very long
because they are so so long
they're hours and hours but with this
guy was able to do that
and i thought yeah you know what you're
talking about there the is sitting on a
twitch stream or
uh a video or a podcast for
two three hours at a time
that's pretty remarkable you know i mean
i can see it with when i when i first
started shooting youtube videos i was
just doing what we call lecture capture
where i would take a camera and i would
plunk it down on a desk while i was
teaching a class and my class sessions
usually went over an hour so you know
the videos were over an hour right and
people would watch that but i think
there was already a structure there of
hey this is how long the class goes so
i'm gonna shut up and listen to this guy
for
you know an hour or so
and and then we'll see what happens
after that
whereas the the formats that we're at
now i mean in the past you would have uh
movies right movies you'd go and sit
your butt down in the seat and along
with all the other people in the theater
and hopefully shut up long enough that
people could watch
an hour and a half to two two and a half
hours or something
and uh i guess you could say we had
other formats where people could talk
for a long time like the linc and
douglas debates were actually quite long
and you know people might give sermons
that were quite long but it wasn't it
wasn't our normal life right where
people would um just sit and consume
content
for hours
almost everything you've described so
far
as scripted or at least has an outline
oh wow whereas right yeah all these are
just like you know kind of stream of
consciousness this is a
fundamentally different form of like
entertainment so that creates a maybe a
greater potential for that
that
semblance of intimacy because it's no
longer the um you know presenter or
performer and audience
it's it's much more along the lines of a
hangout especially when you
like if you look at twitch or any of the
live streaming stuff where they will you
know react to
comments and so there's this like back
and forth this this
you know simulacrum this like poor
representation of actual dialogue that
one would actually have yeah yeah that's
that's quite interesting
i i suppose that started to happen on
shows
where
you know like like the talking had
politics shows where
they would allow people to chime in on
twitter and then they would respond to
it
you know
i guess it's similar to like one of
those uh
you know
long-form talk shows in which they'll
they'll everyone while
a small caller and they'll like let him
talk for like i don't know 30 seconds
and then yeah shut it off and just like
ramble on for another 10 minutes or
where they'd have an audience and they'd
walk out into the audience and give the
mic to somebody right
right
although a lot of that turned out to be
you you should be treating them better
something like that
so uh i'll throw this out to you um are
is unrequited love a
you know parasocial relationship
you know
that's a that's a really great one and i
think here we want to make a distinction
so unrequited love for somebody
that you're already in a parasocial
relationship with or where that's the
tenor of it like you fall in love with a
character
or an actress or a sports figure or
something like that you got their
posters on your wall and you're talking
about them constantly like people who
are
in love do you know annoying their
friends and family
okay so that's one way right and then
you could also have the the you know the
real life unrequited love it's the uh
person that you um interact with at
in the workplace or
they're the barista
and they don't know that you really have
a thing for them
um because you don't tell them or or
maybe you do tell them and they're like
oh i'd really rather we be friends you
know
right
and now you have to as we say carry a
torch right so there that's not
parasocial unless you but could you turn
it parasocial like
so
they
move away
and you stalk them on you know social
media and you keep following what
they're doing
you're now they're an ordinary person
rather than a celebrity but you're
treating them kind of as if they're a
celebrity like you're watching the
so-and-so show
is that is that parasocial
uh i would say that that's veering into
the pair of social like and i think okay
that there is a distinction there um but
it's kind of like
it's being subsumed you have
all unrequited loves yeah and then some
of them can be parasocial and some of
them are like social just like you know
the the girl next door that you've known
forever but like you know you're into
her and she's not yeah yeah
does it make a difference if they know
or not
what do you what do you think i mean
because if they know
they get to
say something about the nature of their
relationship and they can even say hey
you know just uh just move on it'd be
better for you right and then you choose
not to maybe you're more
you're more responsible if you don't or
i i don't know
i'd say you're more responsive you don't
um
but i don't think that that stops it
from being parasocial if you tell them
or not
but
um
so uh
what are
um
[Music]
maybe you know the
benefits that we we've looked at
from some of these potentially
well you know some people
think that that parasocial relationships
could actually be
quite helpful um
but it really does depend on what you're
saying like how how one conducts it you
know how far you go with it so think
about when we talk about role models
role models if we feel
strongly towards them positively and we
model our own behavior or decision
making after them
you know we try to be cool like them we
try to be
good people like they are like take
sports figures right so you know you
take one of the green bay packers
who's an amazing athlete and you're like
oh they give a hundred percent every
game no they give 110 or whatever
proportion it's gonna be right so i'm a
mad yeah that's 120 percent um well you
know the point is that they they
persevere and maybe you should be like
that when somebody
asks you to type up these reports even
though it's not you know very you know
glamorous football playing it's still
something
important um and you know and you could
feel a sort of warmth towards them and
you could idolize them in a certain way
and you could be like you know i'm in a
situation what would donald driver do
you know what would devonta adams do
well i was gonna say if it's donald
driver he's gonna smile and make
everything right
well and also give a lot to charity
right and and be very gracious and stuff
like that i mean i think a lot of people
could uh probably improve their
personalities if they added a little bit
of donald driver to it
although
how much do we know donald driver like
uh the perception of him he's a really
great guy yeah um
but once again like we're we're only
seeing
what we are allowed to see and we don't
might not see him not that i'm assuming
that he's a bad person when he's away
from the spotlight but dr jekyll and mr
hyde kind of thing yeah
but just we don't know
and uh that is the nature of these
parasocial relationships is that
we are being presented a a small subset
of
people and their lives and the way they
interact and that might not at all
reflect
them on the
average or the majority of the time yeah
well going back to the role modeling so
let's say and we'll pick donald driver
let's say he's not he's you know
totally different when he gets home than
he is you know when he's
in public if you had this
positive role modeling going on and you
did feel strongly towards him
that might motivate you more to being
philanthropic or you know taking care of
people and so that i think that's good
right if you if you said okay donald
driver um you know where's this i need
to wear these clothes okay i think that
starts getting
weird but it gets weird because it's off
base because there's some mistaken
inferences i i need to be like this
person
in these
more extraneous things what stoics would
call externals you know
that could be a lot more problematic but
i mean that's how endorsements work
right the celebrity endorses some
product that they probably themselves
don't even use
you know like how many how many um
athletes actually ate wheaties
i'm guessing not too many you know
probably not they probably good food
that's healthier for them and you know
uh but you know the endorsements there
and then then we buy into it
well you're saying that they don't want
to buy a
food that was intended to produce
masturbation
oh the origin of those cereals yeah yeah
i mean i betcha
i bet you there's somebody out there who
has a parasocial relationship
with kellogg
you know not not the not the uh company
but with the guy
the man yeah yeah
yeah given all the things that people
can be obsessed about you know there's
probably somebody who's like he is a
great culture hero
so
let's kind of like go through the
history of this concept and so you were
digging into this
yeah so i mean it's been around for
forever um in ancient times people might
identify with
those that they were hearing about in
their media like the heroes or the gods
or
you know
spirits they might also identify with
artists or musicians or writers
particularly
once those started to attain more and
more social status
so this has been going on for for a long
time this one-sided kind of
relationship that people would have and
we're going to talk about aristotle a
little bit later on aristotle actually
mentions that you can't have a genuine
friendship if it is one-sided you can
wish wish well to the other person for
their own sake you want them to prosper
and do well
but if they don't do that in relation to
you you're not really friends you're
you're an admirer at best right
or
go ahead what is it yeah we've got what
the three that he he puts out is the
nickmenian ethics are what a a friend of
convenience the kinds of friendships
yeah virtue uh pleasure and utility or
convenience yeah right
but even even a friend of utility who's
just you know i mean friend in a very
attenuated sense
there's an acquaintance in this there's
still a back and forth right you you
hang out with them and i don't know you
contribute to their charity because they
invite you to cool parties or something
like that you know
oreo it's the guy that sits in the
cubicle next to you
right yeah there you go it's easy why
not like are you gonna
stew about some guys like whatever he's
just there you know enjoy it so that's
interesting because
you could
you could have an actual
regular friendship with the guy in the
cubicle who's just a you know a schlub
like you
your relationship to the boss way up
there on the top floor that might be a
parasocial relationship right
they don't give you the time of day
but they do send out like emails that
are like
hello um you know acme family we're all
in this together and you're like yeah
man we're all in this together they're
they're talking to me i love this guy or
this lady here
something like that and then everybody
else is looking at you and they're like
don't you get it they they don't care
about you they don't even know who you
are and you're like nope because they
sent me when i had my last performance
review the boss himself
also sent an email
and it said good job and there was even
like i don't know like some drawing in
it or some some some pretty thing he
cares about me
yeah this is
i look at this but there's something
that's usually in in this relationship
that is usually not found in most
parasocial relationships okay in that
the boss does have power over that
person and the decisions of the boss can
materially affect this person
okay
which is an interesting wrinkle uh
definitely a place for
discussion yeah i mean if the packers
win or lose and this year they lost
right uh aft they choked in the the
playoffs as they so often do you know
what's almost predictable
our lives didn't come to an end it's not
like we lost our jobs i mean one guy
lost his job the special teams coach oh
yes because they did so badly but you
know a a a window opened up for another
guy now he's special teams coach so you
know it's kind of a net zero thing but
but going exactly he's very special
wow yeah yeah special teams you know
they especially screwed up this season
yeah
in any case i mean there have been
philosophers that have been talking
about this for a long time and they
usually kind of viewed it as negative um
although
you know maybe maybe we don't have to
always view it the same way like
kierkegaard who suffered quite a bit in
the in the danish media
didn't like the crowd or the public he's
actually got a piece called the crowd is
untruth that's you know a little extreme
but and the crowd are the people who
like
you know the people that that
we smarter people don't don't get into
you know but but we can be just as as
easily i mean
he's got a whole book where he's like i
gotta figure this abraham guy out you
know um maybe that could be kind of
parasocial
so a lot of people have played off of
this and they use their celebrity and i
think you know one of the things that i
i kind of hear you saying earlier is
that in the old days it was probably a
little bit easier to do image management
because we weren't seeing celebrities
all the time you know
um
so that might be something we talk about
but this idea the name of the concept
comes up in this 1956 article so you
know more than half a century ago mass
communication and parasocial interaction
observations on intimacy at a distance
and then it got studied in you know by a
lot of different people
they started looking at interactions
between mass media users and media
figures
different approaches and interpretations
have developed highlighting different
aspects some of them positively some of
them negatively
but but the one thing they do agree on
is if there is a relationship so
sometimes they actually talk instead
about relationship they talk about sorry
who who is this well
who's who is what who is that talking
about this in this article i just you oh
donald horton and richard wall
um
two to researchers
um
[Music]
anyway yeah so you know
sometimes we could talk about it less as
a relationship and more as just
interaction or behavior
um because is there really a
relationship there that's the paradox
that we started with it can be a
relationship if
there aren't two sides to it and that's
why i really like this on
intimacy at a distance yeah yeah you can
feel intimate
towards someone
at a distance and that's not a
technically a relationship
i i you know just the the feeling the
the emotional state of you know an
intimate reaction or yeah
but that does not require both although
it seems like it should
you know i hadn't thought about this
before but now that you bring that up
there's like all these guides out there
for youtubers or
other kind of content producers about
how you should engage your audience
and a lot of it's really cynical you
know when you think about it not cynical
in the old philosophical sense but
cynical and the let's exploit people
kind of sense right and and now that i
think about it a lot of that is about
generating
a
a kind of intimacy where you're letting
people
read stuff in you're not actually like
writing to them and saying hey i love
every each and every one of you and i
care about each and every one of you as
a person
instead um you're like you know you're
saying things that allow them to draw
conclusions that are
um so like barnum statements
okay you gotta explain with that okay
because i don't know what i i actually
only learned that terminology a little
while ago but go ahead
so a barnum statement is a um a
statement that is so vague that allows
the the listener or the reader to um
kind of put themselves into it and so
you'll
see these a lot in horoscopes and so
horoscopes are written in such a way
that they're vague enough that you could
see yourself in in basically any one of
them you can you can go in and you take
you know you've got 12 horoscopes a day
yeah
um 13 if you're actually up on your
stuff and
um and look at each one of the you can
you can uh cut off the titles of these
and and mix them around and every single
one of them will feel like there is
something that is speaking to you yeah
because you see this you say something
like you are going to face a choice
between two alternatives today
right
there's opportunity
waiting right around the corner yeah
or you will
face challenges today but if you
persevere those will turn into rewards
yeah
those are those are perfect and see how
it is how easy it is for us to just make
this stuff up i mean
we could do that with like stock reports
we could be like you know this here's
the most basic one
you know the stock is either going to go
up or it's going to go down
sounds profound right but it's
it's a tautology
or is it a tautology no i think it's
it's it's a it's a disjunction where
both sides have to you know you have to
have one or the other right yeah i mean
there is a third alternative it could
like hold its value and then if you say
that in a sufficiently
pontifical tone people go wow this guy
really knows what he's talking about
so how so how going back how are
parasocial relationships connected with
this barnum effect then this is this
vagueness
um
as you were just talking about and it's
not even just like the people are
talking about youtube but this is
actually in
youtube's creator
uh guide and how they actually present
hey you got a youtube channel how do you
grow your audience and they they put out
some of these things that are
encouraging for parasocial relationships
and so like jesse was you're saying like
tom can like you know you make vague
statements about things that you like um
you put out things that um
are are
uh kind of like these
good feels to your uh your audience in
order to um you know make them
feel closer to yourselves
maybe um you know you're the the more
active youtuber so uh yeah but i heard
one right i didn't follow any of that
advice i i actually you know i'm kind of
a snob so i i put that sort of stuff
aside and i'm like i'm just here for you
know
teaching philosophy and the content and
and you know the way that i did it
people like it um i do actually get some
some negative comments where people are
like this guy talks too slow or you know
he's been over this stuff before why why
can't he just like cut to the chase or i
listen to this on you know
1.25 or 1.5 speed or things along those
lines
so you know i might not be the best
example of how to do that but i mean we
can think about really big successful
youtubers and what they do and you're
right they make these vague statements
that anybody can easily identify with oh
we all have our challenges in life
yeah of course
but if you persevere
and buy my uh you know
campaign
uh or my my um my packets you too can
join the the youtube elites well now
so there's two things going on there
right it could be like i'm gonna sell
how to succeed on youtube and you can
become very successful selling courses
this isn't just for youtube this is like
across the board you can become a great
success in this pyramid scheme where
basically you teach other people how to
become successful even though you're not
successful but you become successful
because you sell so many of these
courses so there's there's there's that
possible
self-referential
aspect right and and what you need for
that is a lot of suckers to say oh well
this guy seems successful i'd better buy
his you know 2 000 package and then i
too can start doing the same sort of
thing as him only to find of course that
the ground has already been taken up by
the the people who are successful um
but you know you could have other kinds
of
things that are being put out there
that aren't just this
success success it could be about like
success in life or success in love or
your career and they could they could
give you a nice vague advice about that
like you know if you smile at people
more people will like you
but don't smile like this you know with
a grimace or something like that and a
real smile
um
and and you know somebody giving you
advice like that it could generate this
oh they they care for me they understand
my problems that i have
you know
right
so um
are we creating parasocial relationships
here
you mean with wisdom for life uh
that works
[Laughter]
maybe um this is a a better question
just for you
because you do have
a generally greater following um and you
also do like as you said you are
a little stodgy and you you kind of a
screw the um the usual way that most
youtubers produce content but you do
have a couple of things that are a
little bit more intimate like your um
greg seller stories yeah yeah and i do
amas and i think that's another way that
people can get
kind of uh
sucked in you know
um
i guess like we've put out on
what a
couple days worth of um
oh right audio nowadays and you know we
don't like shy away from talking about
some of our our personal issues and our
our lives and so we're definitely you
know
giving off enough information that is
usually reserved for those people who
are on
more close relationships and so there's
definitely you know a potential yeah
that is a great point and i think that
the
like
always on
you know gotta produce content like
youtube for example wants you to have a
video a day at least you know
and so the way a lot of people will do
that is by having you know uh live chats
with streaming and then they'll reveal
all sorts of things about what's going
on with them and that does produce this
um this this uh
sentiment
that illusion of intimacy yeah yeah
um and then i i guess another thing is
like
we're we're talking directly at our
screens which you know
when it's the two of us it's a little
bit less but it's just one of us it's
you know you can look directly into our
eyes because we're looking right at the
camera and uh there's definitely a you
know
a really basic
uh closeness that we as humans derive
from having eye to eye contact
that is so true and now that i think
about it you know i've been producing
youtube videos now for 11 years
and i'd done a lot of public speaking
before that because i was um
teaching in the classroom you know and
then i was doing what we call public
philosophy like going to libraries and
giving talks and stuff like that
and so
at first when i was recording i would i
would do so with an audience namely a
classroom and it wasn't just an audience
it was people there who had read the
text and hopefully and we're going to
ask some questions and respond in ways
and stuff like that and then i found
myself
shooting videos where i would just shoot
him in a classroom
at first at marist college
i'd find an open classroom and just
start recording and actually every once
in a while like one of the custodians
would like open the door and be like
you'll write in here you know and i'd be
like yeah i'm just shooting a video you
know um because they weren't used to
people being on their own talking to an
empty room
it took me a little while to get used to
talking to an empty room as well but i
would i would remember that hey my
students are going to be on the other
end of this
so i would like visualize who i'm i'm
talking to
and now you know i can just get up and
shoot a a video and i don't even have to
think about it
um and i am looking at the camera or
looking at the book or the chalkboard or
whatever it's going to be and it seems
very natural and and a lot of people
will say oh it feels it feels like i'm
in a classroom i like that you know um
and i suppose with people who are not
doing that but they're just like news
anchors or
i know sports commentators they're
they're looking at the camera all the
time right that's all i mean they have a
teleprompter that has words for them
um
but most of the time they're actually
like either they're looking at each
other or they're looking into the camera
and you have that feeling like you're
being in a
a place with them you know
um and so yes to continue on our thing
yeah
on we we also do this regularly we do
this you know hopefully every two weeks
and so if you're a regular
uh
viewer that that's you know twice a
month you're seeing us which you know
for some of my friends that's a lot more
than i see them because they feel free
to develop a parasocial relationship if
you want to
um
we do have a dialogue but it's not
usually with our viewers for the most
part it's it's just between us yeah
you know that makes me wonder about
something that we hadn't really put into
the the show notes
um
what if it is like
a you know a a pair or
three people or you know like a show
right
where you have
it's it's the repartee between them like
you know for example i'll i'll admit
that i like a show that would probably
surprise people who think that i have
high moral values and stuff like that i
love always sunny in philadelphia you
know
the gang right they're all total
reprobates oh yeah they're nev there's
never going to be a moral redemption arc
that actually holds they actually bring
other people down like poor cricket you
know oh god freaking cricket
and
you know um would the show
would the show remain what it is if like
half of the cast left
i i don't know i mean
i don't know that i have parasocial
relations with them because i just like
watching what they do and then i stop
thinking about it
after i've you know had my haha so funny
stuff and and sometimes been grossed out
by them um but let's say i really got
into the show you know like let's say i
lived in philly and and i was like oh
these are people i can totally relate to
you know i mean i know this bar that
that they go to when they're not at
paddy's
um and i start like i think they do
shoot in l.a oh do they okay wow yeah
well there you go
um so maybe sorry to
continue on i i'm sorry to deflate your
bubble there yeah i mean i mean half the
shows that we're watching
um they're not existing in any place
that we can be i mean think about you
know things that in the star trek
universe we're not in outer space
but we get attached to these characters
and
maybe oh go ahead
just you know for for the sunny crew
um
they're entertaining to watch but these
are people that i definitely
never want to hang out with
well as as them right yeah
but you can follow the actors oh yeah
twitter stuff like that and
and i think people get it quite attached
to them you know yeah
but um
you know i very much enjoy uh mythic
quest i think it's an apple tv okay
that's got um
both um
uh mac was a rob mclaney and um and the
guy who plays uh rickety cricket okay
that's nice
yeah
also danny poody who is uh maybe i have
a slight so a parasocial relationship
because um
uh one
um he's in one of my favorite shows of
all time community
um
and two he is also a graduate of
marquette so he's from milwaukee or has
at least close ties to milwaukee so um
now that's interesting because so when
aristotle talks about friendship and
we've used him as a reference point here
one of the things that he stresses
is
solidifying friendships having things in
common
and you know we'd like to have things
like oh we're really great people and
we're you know making the world a better
place and all that but it could just be
like hey we went to the same high school
you know so we feel like we have a
connection there you know or we're from
we're from the same city or
um
things along those lines right or uh you
know you're wearing a packer shirt today
and um if i was at a bar with you that
would be something i'd use in order to
strike up a conversation if i wanted to
now that's that's interesting because
there's two ways you could go with that
you could be like oh man the packers i
love you know love aaron rodgers love
you know uh devonte adams or something
like that you could also like go up to
me and be like the packers suck man yeah
yeah so to round out my idea of like why
are we creating a parasocial
relationship the converse here is um we
are not directly fostering the
relationships to capitalize on it um so
like at least that's um we're not
particularly fostering it for
you know nefarious sense or at least
monetary yes although sometimes people
involved in parasocial relationships
especially if they are involved with
other people
who are similarly involved with the same
figures will like jockey for position
like i'm the better fan i i know this
this person more they'd rather hang out
with me you know
yeah
um and a couple of other things
are um
i guess i don't hang out in stream i
don't think you stream it anyway
well i do these live stream like ama and
political theory discussions and then
people can chat in the side right and
then i respond to what they're saying
um
and at least within this particular show
um
our the presentation here is presented
as a conversation between
us too and not a conversation directly
to the other person
yeah we're not we're not doing a lot of
calls to action although you know when
we have practices i suppose those are
right
yeah
we're not we're not inviting fan mail
you know tell us all about yourself
complete our questionnaire
[Laughter]
you know i i actually i mean there's a
lot of people who i like and admire
um i've actually written to two
celebrities
total in the course of my
time
one of them was ian hill of
judas priest who's a great bassist and i
wrote him a fan letter about i don't
know eight nine years back after we saw
him in concert i actually wrote it on
this like i have this special paper that
says like you know dr gregory b sadler
on it for like it was given to me as a
gift a long time ago so yeah he might
get a kick out of that you know
having a philosopher write him never got
a response i don't know if it even
reached him or not
but i had an email exchange with
an actor who was on the show i don't
know if you remember andromeda
yeah
with uh um kevin sorbo as the captain
yeah now the kevin sorbo is the captain
i kind of like that guy kevin sorbo as
the person who he is
man i can't stand that guy
but i the the guy who is the nietzschean
keith hamilton cobb
um i wrote him and i i think maybe i
left like a comment on something that
he'd written somewhere and it was about
nichianism
and he wrote me an email and then we we
exchanged some emails back and forth and
i got to ask them things like well
you know i mean what what were you like
thinking when you're putting yourself
into this neat tune and i was i was
trying to avoid the like you know um
where do you get your ideas from kind of
stuff that people must always be like
fanboying him with you know or what is
it like playing a nation
because i'm somebody who actually you
know works on nietzsche and i was like
this guy uh you know his portrayal of it
made sense i i like where it was going
and uh it was it was an interesting
conversation but at a certain point
because he must get a lot of interaction
he's like
i hope you understand but um i don't
engage with fans more than a certain
amount of time
um
wish you well and i was like that's cool
you know um i can put that in my uh
pack in case i ever like become famous
that's how i handle it you know
so one of the things i really wanted to
get into is kind of like what are the
the consequences of
these things and and why we feel
that we have such a strong reaction to
this um and so this is uh kind of a
mental model of people and so like you
know everyone that we have a
relationship with we kind of build this
mental model of how they are how they'll
react to certain things once presented
with
different things and kind of
expectations of how they're going to act
in all sorts of situations
and
um all
of our relationships kind of depend on
these even our closest ones and this is
kind of the reason why
um what our loved ones
do things that we
don't expect that there's um
such a a negative reaction because
dissonance right yeah because between
what we expect them to do and what
they're actually doing and we're we're
angry
that the
the mental model or the mental
like homunculus that of that person that
lives in our brain isn't matching up
with the real world
counterpart i got you this gift and i
knew you'd love it but you hate it uh
what's happening here right yeah
um so we love the idea of the person and
not the person themselves a lot and um
and
uh we create this you know kind of
idealized version of the the people and
so this this is one of the things that
happens when you happen to meet these
people especially these one that you
have paracels relationships and their
off-screen persona does not at all match
up
with the true thing and i'm trying to
i'll be a little bit vague here i i
recently
was in the presence of a friend of mine
who met one of his
idols okay
and
but you're not gonna say who it is right
no okay
can you give anyone answer
uh someone in the basketball world okay
that's that's sufficiently vague yeah
yeah um and
uh
once we met this individual the the way
that he portrayed himself was on
a loof and crass and something that is
totally not presented within
the the material that he produces so
like his action his
um persona on screen is significantly
different than the persona at least that
he presented to us when we met this
person
and it it it was sad to see my my friend
get totally deflated yeah in the
reaction to seeing this particular thing
now
you could like say well maybe he's
having an off day or something like that
but there's still that that crack that's
that's appearing
so this is the kind of the basis of the
don't ever meet your heroes
yeah you know uh lev shestoff who's a
very unsystematic in fact
anti-systematic um russian philosopher
who i like quite a bit
he talks about people
um no this is back in you know like the
early 1900s meeting meeting their their
literary um
idols
and he says that they come in and they
expect because they've read these books
they're like oh this person produced
this wonderful literature
they're going to be so cultured and
witty and stuff like that
and he says that's not usually the case
you know
creativity is not uh something that
works that way you know a lot of it's
flukes and
sometimes it's just you know you you
work real hard and then you get to take
it easy after a while and the last thing
you want is some fan coming around
wanting more of the same you've already
poured your heart out into
this work you know you don't want
somebody trying to make you
do that same thing again you know
yeah so
uh
you know actually
it was just i was just thinking of like
what second well i was gonna say it
could be very tough
in certain fields like if you're a rock
and roll star right
you had some big albums back in the late
80s you know you had the long hair
you know you were partying thinking
sticks
well i think like guns and roses
okay
yeah that's a great example
what happens when you're fat and balding
and you can't sing as well or
you know i mean slash can still play
really great i mean you look at axel
rose and you're like
time takes its toll man you know you
can't you can't um provide what it is
that people who had their
images of the uh the great rock and
roller fixed back then where's actually
some managed to do that you know biff
byford of saxon 70 years old says he's
gonna he's never gonna retire still has
his long hair it's all white of course
uh but and he still moves around on
stage quite a bit
um that's that's a different kind of
thing
um
and so i said i mean but i don't know
that many people have parasocial
relations with with sax and the way they
did with guns and roses you know right
so uh to kind of finish off the thought
here like this reminded me a lot of this
idea of
um
the map is not the terrain and so we can
create these maps yeah of people in our
minds
but
you know you use a map but it's a it's a
poor representation of the real thing
like you you'll you'll see a street and
you'll see a green blob but that is what
is that is it trees is it grass
bushes yeah no and so we have these
rough outlines of these people
especially because they have
given you
uh only a subset of their time um that
that will not map on to their actual
everyday
relationships um
you know a show that really plays with
that a lot
curb your enthusiasm where it's showing
larry david as being like the jerk that
he actually
is all right
and so um because of of most of these
parasocial relationships especially ones
with like
uh streaming that you have enough
material it allows you to produce these
mental maps a lot better than you would
um
many other people especially you know if
you compare them to you know the the
stars of the screen yeah and yesteryear
um and because of the the crater um can
be so good at on producing these maps
that you want to be
associated with and and trust you can
then potentially um use those for for
monetary gain or other you know
potentially nefarious means
yeah or even just have a very loyal fan
base it probably feels good to have
people liking you and loving you and
sending fan letters and stuff like that
you know
i mean
i don't know that many people write
letters these days anymore but i guess
you could have a whole bunch of you can
have your email box filled up or
something like that right
so do we have any examples of some uh
relationships gone wrong well there's
there's tons of them out there and i
think actually probably well like your
friend would be one i think a lot of us
could like come up with dozens of
examples off the top of our head of
somebody who got really invested in some
sort of celebrity
and then um
something went wrong like you know one
of the things they talk about is uh
parasocial breakups where somebody is
like on the air
and then their show gets discontinued
and now you're like i need my fix
where's this person you know
um
how am i gonna live my life without so
and so
and then there's uh the parasocial
you know uh betrayal which is not just
like an absence of that person but them
doing something going back to my kind of
like maps of uh individuals
that they have an expectation of what
they should be doing all of a sudden
they present something that you feel
will find an asthma they're like how
dare you
why would you ever do this this is
something and so the problem is that
when you have you know someone that you
actually have a close relationship with
you can apologize you know
see our um
last episode exactly
on apologies um but uh because it is
this pair of social relationship there's
no
good way for one to actually atone for
those transgressions
at least not in the intimate way you can
say like you can have an apology video
but that doesn't
doesn't usually do the same work as uh
when you have a relationship and someone
kind of is
yeah it's not like you can do
one-to-one apologies because there's not
enough time and you're not sure who to
apologize to and if you did it like with
okay now the next 20 of you come in here
and i'm going to give an apology that's
not going to work right no yeah that's a
that's a great example um i mean one
that actually comes to mind right away
is the famous um john hinckley jr he
shot ronald reagan shot a bunch of other
people too a policeman secret service
officer critically wounded the press
secretary james brady almost killed the
president and why did he do it well he
was trying to impress jodie foster and
you hear that and you're like
what
uh i mean how the hell would she know
what you were doing and this is not the
way to impress a person anyway shooting
a bunch of people but he thought that
was uh
a good way to do it
um
and i think we can
there's other cases of people doing
similarly bad things to impress
somebody who they thought it would draw
attention to
um and it usually backfires um
as a matter of fact albert camus now i
think about this in the myth of sisyphus
he's talking about suicide at the
beginning and he talks about this poet
who
couldn't get people to read his poetry
so he killed himself and then of course
he became famous for killing himself and
then people read his poetry
and then they were like oh it's not very
good
[Laughter]
so it really backfired nobody would have
known that he was a hack if he just like
kept living
hey have you met kept living kept
working on it you might have actually
got good on you you're right you're
right yeah i mean i don't know if that
would if that was really
a real person or whether kamu was just
making that up but
yeah um and then there's seal um
obviously those people that use their
positions of fame and power to um
try to exploit money or and or like
sexual favors out of people which are
you know um
that that's what uh i think that's kind
of like james franco was um
caught doing recently as well as
the other that is
there are hundreds of people that have
kind of done that i mean the whole idea
of groupies right
right but i think uh his was a little
bit
more
worse because he was like he created a
school and was like using his power at
the school to like a acting school
that's yeah that's that's skeevy
yeah there's a whole bunch of different
like things going wrong there you could
say right yeah
um but that's what happens when you get
like those people that like really feel
close to you and you have a loyal
foundation they want to do something for
you you know one of the things that you
have in the show notes is like youtubers
um
[Music]
and donations
i remember when i
had to reach like a certain level that i
qualified for what's called super chat
and super chat is where people when
you're doing a live stream
they will um you know like ask a
question and they'll donate a certain
amount of money and then their thing
goes to the top right
and i never encourage people to do that
but some people do you know
um but a lot of youtubers will be like
hey you know this is a great way for you
to connect with me you know and they're
just directly exploiting that that sense
of intimacy with the person you know
giving giving somebody 20 bucks or five
bucks or a dollar is not a form of
intimacy you know right
yeah it's
a
contractual relationship let me put it
this way there's no love language that's
actually currency you know
right ooh okay um
uh brienne
no i don't i forget who's whose thing
that is but
hey you know we should we should talk
about our practice because we're getting
right really close to the top of the
hour
so you've got a good title for this
and incongruity of value
and so this is uh something we're
pulling from the anki writing or the
otherwise known as the handbook of
epictetus and so uh from the 44th
section of this um
these reasonings are unconnected i'm
richer than you therefore i am better i
am more eloquent than you therefore i am
better the connection is rather this i
am richer than you therefore my property
is greater than yours i am more eloquent
than you therefore my style is better
than yours but you after all are neither
property nor style
yeah i i really like this
i mean there's so many great things at
the end caridian but this is
particularly good because it's targeting
one of the mistaken
inferences that we make so easily and
that other people exploit and then try
to encourage us to make so you know
there's all these things prestige money
being able to talk well being physically
attractive
having great athletic ability pick
whatever you want right that's set
seemingly set other people above us and
then we're invited to connect with them
as lower to higher and
you know we can i think we can recognize
that somebody has great talents or
something along those lines
without assuming that thereby because as
a fan
we have a relationship with them we can
love them we can be other excellent
musician
you know
but we don't have to we don't have to
lower ourselves
in doing so
i mean what would you like to add to
that i feel like so it's a
like
we can appreciate but we don't need to
bring that appreciation
into something greater than what it is
okay it's kind of like you an
aesthetics of a person um
their full range
i like that addition
as well you are neither property nor
style you
you yourself in the core of who you are
you may not measure up against you know
people that you can't possibly measure
up against star athletes
awesome musicians
people who've been practicing talking
and have teleprompters you know all that
sort of stuff it'd be silly for you to
do that but that's not who you are so
you don't have to invest yourself in
that
[Music]
right
so i think we need to uh finish off
today's thoughts
with a little bit of some words from
michael kane
my circle of friends are not actors at
all
none of them are actors really because
they're not available they're always off
somewhere
[Music]
so
[Music]
you